in the aftermath of a leftist terrorist
attempting to murder dozens of
Republican Congress people there are
widespread calls from both right and
left to tamp down the level of violent
language regularly utilized in political
discourse it was a starry-eyed idea kind
of dumb and was never likely to
withstand a test of hard-nosed politics
and naturally it didn't within two weeks
the opponents of President Trump went
right back to the violent language they
were decrying on Thursday responding to
the Senate health bill that would trim
around the edges of Obamacare while
restructuring Medicaid senator Elizabeth
Warren took a political hot tomahawk to
Republicans calling their bill blood
money then the reactor Johnny Depp has
been playing a fade pirate both on
screen and off for the last decade
who said that maybe an actor should
assassinate Trump then there was Josh
Fox a leftist film producer who followed
up with this chim quote Mitch McConnell
is a terrorist
Donald Trump is a terrorist this bill
terrorizes people and sentence his poor
people to death
here's leftist pressure organization
Media Matters quote what pundits call a
moderate Senate health care bill will
kill people then there were these
protesters quote GOP unveils health care
bill while protesters bleed and scream
the government wants to kill me and the
risk aughts workin democratic consultant
fact the GOP health care bill will kill
Americans hashtag save ACA yes
the violent language left thought was so
terrible that it supposedly led to the
Oklahoma City bombing and shooting of
Gabby Giffords just had to stop but not
the violent language that by the same
theory may have impacted the
Congressional shooter that has to
continue after all how will people know
how violence and threatening Republicans
are a must Democrats describe them as
murderers and terrorists I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
all righty so a lot to get to today
we're going to talk about Johnny Depp
and his fate piracy in just a second
we're also going to talk about would we
go through the health care bill which I
now have had a chance to read so we'll
talk about everything that is in the
Senate health care bill but before we do
any of that I want to remind you that in
these times it is useful to own some
precious metal if you feel insecure
about the future of the economy if it
looks like the economy might be slowing
in some ways that you're worried about
foreign threat that may impact the
economy if you're worried about
inflation that's why you need to talk to
my friends over at Birch gold group
they've a long-standing track record of
continued success thousands of satisfied
clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
from the Better Business Bureau right
now if you contact them they can give
you a free information kit on physical
precious metals and that 16-page kit
reveals how gold and silver can protect
your savings how you can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds
and into a precious metals IRA go to
birchgold.com slash Brendon's
birchgold.com slash pan and by the way
if your personal collection of precious
metals a beautiful stuff I mean like
this is a 5 ounce silver america the
beautiful' coin and you can see that
pretty cool
the teddy roosevelt pretty they also
have the one ounce silver American Eagle
proof coins so you can get these coins
you can stash them and they will still
be worth something when your dollar is
worth nothing eventually so make sure
that you go over to Birch gold group and
talk to them right now birchgold.com
slash event ask all your questions at
least part of your portfolio should be
in precious metals to hedge against
inflation and governmental intervention
that's what Birch gold is for
birchgold.com slash venues the slash man
that they know that we sent you okay so
as the Republicans released their Senate
health care bill which we'll go through
in a second and talk about I don't like
it I think it doesn't repeal Obamacare
it does some good things because most
Republican bills do some good things but
if this is the big Obamacare repeal we
were told about this is not that this is
not what that is and it is a lie for
Republicans who suggest that it is and
they're a couple of serious Republican
political problems associated with this
health care bill but before we get to
that I want to talk about the Democrats
new obsession really isn't new I mean
this has been since the election with
killing Trump and
saying violent things about Republicans
and being just quite terrible so you
know we talked in the aftermath the
congressional shooting about when
language is connected to violence and I
said that I'm not going to explicitly
blame language for violence unless the
blank which explicitly calls for
violence however I also said that when
you have increased violent language when
you have an increased tenor in political
debate suggests that your political
opposition terrorists who are benefiting
from blood money that there is a small
fringy group of people who are going to
be set off by this and again I'm not
going to draw a direct linkage but I
think there is clearly an indirect
language linkage language can affect
random people for sure if you think of
speech as a giant circle and then the
the group of same people as mostly
falling within this circle who
understand what speeches and then there
are outliers out here who can be set off
as the circle of speech expands to
include more violent speech then what
you will see is that the circle starts
to shrink actually and the number of
reasonable people who understand this is
meant not to be violent shrinks and you
start to exclude some of the people on
the fringes who start to become
irrational and crazy anyway
the Democrats have obviously been
engaging in this sort of stuff for a
while Johnny Depp was making headlines
last night because he was speaking net
first of all actors should never speak
outside of their Hollywood roles there's
a reason people write lines for them
it's because actors are generally not
the most intelligent people on earth I
know a lot of actors there's a reason
there are stereotypes about actors they
memorize one particularly movie actors
who memorize three lines at a time I
mean not even stage actors have to
memorize an entire play but movie actors
memorize three lines at a time no one
thinks that Johnny Depp is some sort of
genius also I don't know why Johnny
Depp's look is now a homeless man who
killed three other homeless people and
then assembled their wardrobe it
probably cost him thousands of dollars
Greg Gutfeld says he looks like a
refugee from Hot Topic I think that's
probably correct it looks like he raided
my grandmother's drawer for that for
that blue bracelet and then he found a
teenage girl and robbed her car for some
of those other bracelets and then it
looks like he went over to the local
jewelry store and knocked the debt and
knocked it over
for those blingy rings or
alternatively he went to a candy shop
and just spent a lot of money there and
then he grabbed a hat that may have come
from a bad guy in western or also may
have come from a hipster I'm going to go
with probably from the hipster and he
got a Michael Jackson silk black shirt
in order to from from the dead man's
closet in any case here was Johnny Depp
who has been playing a Fae pirate really
since the first Pirates of the Caribbean
it's sad because Johnny Depp used to be
a pretty good actor and now Johnny Depp
just does the Lone Ranger as a favorite
and then he does the same Tyra isn't a
pirate and then he does Black Mass he
tries not to be a fave high rep ADIZ
order fails and even the fááá-- pirate
sort of infuses his his attempts to be a
Boston gangster anyway here's Bay pirate
Johnny Depp talking about how he would
like to kill President Trump we have an
occasion I think he needs I was going to
be am a person be horrible I'd like I
like to roll apart with women who last
time an actor assassinated the president
[Applause]
imitating metaphor I'm not an actor I
like to live my life for a living you
know I'm just like I'm a Randy pirate
you can if maybe let me just tell you
man I'm I've been playing this semi gay
pirate for years and I've made bajillion
dollars off of it and blown nearly all
of it on stupidity but you know I have
some things to say about politics
I mean producting we're gonna play
pirate play a pirate iron anyway so the
Democrats have have little beyond this
sort of violent language there they're
beginning to realise that and so all
hell is breaking loose in the Democratic
Party Bernie Sanders is going out there
and he's openly proclaiming our brand
sucks because he would like to be the
brand yes he wants the brand of the
Democratic Party to be a crazy old loon
bag from Vermont who used to vacation in
the USSR and is a socialist but it is
not my fault that I love putting so much
I had to buy a second vacation home just
to store all of my pudding as well as
Ben and Jerry's ice cream which is quite
delicious although it hurts my dentures
because it is very cold so I like to
wait until it melts into a soupy
concoction which I can then eat but
slowly to a straw while looking out at
the lake in my vacation home Bernie
Sanders go
Democratic congressman Tim Ryan told the
New York Times just the other day that
quote our brand is worse than Trump is
he right I mean is the Democratic brand
he maybe bro Democrat look I speak as
longer serving independent in American
congressional history the Democratic
brand is pretty bad i mean i don't i
think the Trump in a brand is also
pretty bad as is the Republican brand
that's why so many people are giving up
on politics they're looking in
Washington and what the average American
is saying I'm in a lot of pain my kid
can't afford to go to college I'm making
10 bucks an hour what are you going to
do for me and they don't hear much
coming out of Washington okay so he's
right that the Democrats have a terrible
brand I think that his his
recommendation that the brand move
further the left is kind of insane
Democratic Representative Tim Ryan he
came out and he said that Nancy Pelosi
who is now under fire after the loss in
GA six listen Pelosi's brand is awful
and
is true okay if you look at the ga6
races I mentioned yesterday and the day
before if you look at the Georgia sixth
race the name that was national those
mentioned the most in that race was not
Trump it was Nancy Pelosi and here's Tim
Ryan pointing that out well what I
really think is that leader Pelosi
looking forward to the 2018 election has
to ask yourself this question do I help
Democrats win swing districts which we
need to win in 2018 or do I not and have
an honest dialogue with herself and I
just I think the answer is obvious in
the interactive easy to go IIIi think
that if we are going to win this we're
going to regain the majority in 2018 we
have to have new leadership okay so even
the Democrats are starting to realize
they have a problem here meanwhile Nancy
Pelosi is gripping with that death grip
of her gnarled fingers on to power in
the house here is Nancy Pelosi dentures
a-movin talking about how she is the
greatest petition who ever lived ever in
the history of the United States and I
don't understand why people are so angry
at me all the time it's just terrible a
master legislator I am mayor plus
litigious politically astute leader I am
my leadership is recognized by many of
them the country and that is why I'm
able to attract the support that I do
which is essential to our election sad
to say I'm well liked in beautiful and
everyone loves me good luck Nancy Pelosi
with all of us so here's the thing as I
said yesterday the Republicans have the
upper hand because the Democrats are in
disarray
what can bring the Democrats together is
not just an unpopular president like
president Trump and will talk about what
he's been doing over the last 24 hours
but also they need a piece of
legislation to rally around so that they
can get their base out and so that they
can get people on the edge to vote
well we view Republicans home what they
need is a piece of legislation that is
so polarizing that they can that they
can grab on to it and hold on to it and
use it as a club to be a Republican this
is what happened in 2010 after Barack
Obama pushed forward the auto bailouts
and he pushed forward made what was
essentially the National
in the auto industry and stimulus
package and pushed forward Obamacare and
then in 2010 Republicans wiped out
Democrats okay in 1994 it was Bill
Clinton's Hillary care proposal that led
Republicans to wipe out Democrats so
what is the big proposal from
Republicans naturally they decide to
play right into Democrats hands so they
could have started with tax reform they
could have they could have attempted to
get 60 votes on tax reform they could
have started with even an infrastructure
bill that wouldn't have been so
polarizing I'm talking politically now
not even from a conservative point of
view just politically if you want to win
the last thing you start with is
touching the health care system because
the health care system is already
collapsing one of two things going to
happen either you're going to do a full
overthrow of the health care system that
actually fixes it but it's unpopular
because there's a transition period for
any health care system or you are going
to leave it in place and let it die and
or there there's a third possibility
which is the worst of both which is you
make some changes around the edges that
may be beneficial in some ways but you
own the continued failure and that's of
course what Republicans are choosing
because they are stupid so here is what
is in the Republican Senate Obamacare
light bill so there are a couple of
things in here that are good there are
tax cuts ready date cuts taxes it gets
rid of the employer mandate and it also
and it also restructures Medicaid so
Medicaid right now is basically an
open-ended program where the federal
government is absorbing the increase in
the number of people who are rushing
onto Medicaid and then giving grants out
on a need-based basis as opposed to a
per capita flat rate basis to the states
okay that is a recipe for unending debt
as far as getting rid of the taxes and
getting rid of the individual mandate
and getting rid of the employer mandate
and all this the problem is that if you
keep the central Obamacare regulations
in place what you're really doing by
getting rid of all of this is blowing up
spending because if you don't have taxes
to cover the cost of Obamacare if you do
not have mandates to force healthy
people into the Obama care system or
into the the individual health insurance
market then there is no one to pay for
the sick people who Obamacare forces
insurance companies to cover that is the
problem you are exacerbating the death
spiral that Republicans talk about
Republicans talk about the Obamacare
death spiral there's not enough money to
pay for this insurers are dropping out
so they can't make money off of it so
what do we do well Republicans just made
that actually worse with this Senate
bill because the bill retains
Obamacare's core
regulatory scheme and as I said
yesterday the bill is not designed to
actually get rid of Obamacare it's not
designed to lower taxes it is designed
to lower the debt number so that they
can get a tax cut through which is
basically the again to the tax point it
is designed to restructure Medicaid
which is a good thing a very good thing
avec roi is head over heels for the bill
because it restructures Medicaid which
is a good thing and then it is designed
to let Republicans say that repealed
Obamacare which is actually a really bad
thing because you don't want to live the
American people about repealing Obama
care when he didn't repeal it because
you're going to take ownership of a non
free-market system in the name of the
free-market which is always a disaster
for Republicans so first of all six
things about this bill first insurance
companies will still be mandated to
cover pre-existing conditions the minute
you force insurance companies to do this
they begin hemorrhaging cash because
people will wait until they get sick to
get insurance the bill gets rid of the
individual mandate okay so it doesn't
force people into the system which means
that these insurance companies will
start to go bankrupt or they will start
to raise their rates dramatically which
of course does not decrease the price of
premiums it increases the price of
premiums the Republican bill leans
heavily on subsidies and does away with
the mandates and taxes and that
basically destroys the Obamacare
individual market general horowitz of
conservative review has this exactly
right he says the bill merely loosens
existing waiver authority up to the
discretion of HHS for a few regulations
a provision that will not be strong
enough to signal flexibility to insurers
enough to reduce premiums so the idea
here would be that if you got rid of a
lot of the regulations that insurers
would compete to reduce premiums the
bill doesn't do enough to do that the
bill REE enshrines a bunch of subsidies
to insurance companies as I talked about
from Peter Sudirman or Reason magazine
yesterday the Republicans originally
opposed the idea that the federal
government was going to subsidize
insurance companies now they're saying
that it's great that the federal
government is subsidizing insurance
companies and that is not great okay
begin the reason they're subsidizing the
insurance companies is because they kept
all of the Obamacare regulations the
bill also provides new entitlements for
middle-income Americans so right now
Obamacare gives subsidies for insurance
purchase the families of four making
four times the federal poverty level
it's about a hundred thousand dollars
the Senate Republican bill reduces that
to eighty six thousand dollars but as
prices rise which they will continue to
do given the continuation of the
regulations the subsidies are not
going to be enough now this is still
better than the system that was in place
from the house so far as covering people
and not forcing them onto Medicare but
it is a giant subsidy system it is an
entitlement it alters Medicaid and this
is a good thing but it doesn't mostly
down the road so originally the House
bill that was proposed would have begun
rolling back federal funding on a
need-based basis from beginning in 2020
and ending the open-ended funding of
expansion of Medicaid enrollees now the
rollback has been kicked back to 2021
you know why it's because it's after
Trump's re-election and in 2025 it
creates a growth cap on Medicaid
payments linked to inflation rather than
health cost inflation which means that
basically instead of the federal
government's Medicaid reimbursement
being linked to the cost of health care
it's linked just to the dollar well the
problem with that of course is that that
means that Medicaid reimbursements are
going to drop which is okay because that
forces people under private insurance
which they should be getting anyway but
it is never going to materialize anyway
because it's 2025 if you really think
that it's now 2016 2017 if you really
think that eight years from now anything
is going to be certain then you don't
know how government works
the bill does defund Planned Parenthood
this is stopped to the conservatives it
does it for one year okay Medicaid is
not able to fund Planned Parenthood for
one year not for four years
not for ten years for one year and
finally as I say the individual mandate
in taxes disappear which would be good
except for it exacerbating the Obamacare
death spiral for which Republicans will
now be blamed so I think Nate silver
basically has this right I'm just being
intellectually honest here this bill is
not a health care revision it is it is
about restructuring Medicaid which is
good but it does so in the long term
when it's not actually gonna materialize
and it is about tax cuts and ensuring
that Republicans can get tax reform
through well what this means that
there's been some blowback from some of
the Republicans in the Senate I would
not expect that senator Cruz and Senator
Lee maybe are going to stand against
this I think that they may be posing an
opening bargaining position you know I
would hope that they would stand against
the bill that doesn't repeal Obamacare
after Ted Cruz shut down the government
in order to propose the repeal of
Obamacare I don't see why things have
changed here senator Cruz talking about
you can hear that there's a little bit
of wiggle room here senator Cruz I think
would would be interested in probably
finding some sort of solution that
allows him to save face
we've been working collaboratively that
entire time trying to solve the problems
the underlying problems in healthcare
this current draft doesn't get the job
done but I believe we can get to yes I
believe we can get this done there is an
agreement to be reached and I have been
for the last five months working around
the clock to get to that agreement and I
still believe we can get there key to
getting an agreement to getting a bill
that can pass is we need common-sense
reforms in the bill that lower the cost
of premiums the single biggest reason
that so many people are unhappy with
Obamacare that are hurting under
Obamacare is because it's caused
premiums to skyrocket when I'm home in
Texas I hear over and over again from
Texans who say I can't afford health
insurance because of Obamacare we've got
to fix that the current draft circulated
this morning doesn't do nearly enough
the problem is did not - lowers about
actually lower premiums we can stop it
there the only reason that we're going
to be able to lower cost of premiums is
by getting rid of the court Obamacare
regulations on pre-existing conditions
the bill isn't going to do that we're
going to get to the rest of the
Republican reaction why Democrats are
chortling over the secretly but first I
want to say thank you to our friends
over at the u.s. ECA this is the u.s.
concealed-carry Association so let's say
that somebody breaks into your house the
middle of the night you grab your gun
and you shoot them first of all if you
won't know how to shoot them then you
should visit us ECA they do have
firearms training courses firearm safety
courses but beyond that once you shoot
them then you could be in trouble with
the law even if you did the right thing
and that's why you SCCA make sure that
you have the resources and make sure
that you are legally and financially
protected for after you pull the trigger
they educate you they train you and to
make sure that you are legally and
financially protected after you pull the
trigger and also they are focused on
getting more guns into the hands of
responsible law-abiding Americans like
you so in honor of the fourth of July
they've an awesome giveaway they are
doing right now the great American
giveaway you can go to defend my family
now calm and register defend my family
now calm registry get five chances to
win 1776 dollars worth of guns and ammo
1776 get at 1776 dollars worth of guns
and ammo at defend my family now calm
you register
you can give them your email address and
now you get access to all of these
materials anyway which is awesome you
should do it even if they weren't doing
a giveaway but they are doing a giveaway
so why not take advantage you have five
chances to win 1776 dollars toward the
gun and ammo of your choice which is
super cool again defend my family now
calm right now its defend my family now
it's again all of the resources are
invaluable and the fact that you also
get a chance to and the fact that you
get a chance to get the firearms and the
ammo at the same time is SuperDuper cool
again it's defend my family now.com
defend my family now
okay so you know Ted Cruz sounds like he
wants to vote for the thing this I think
this is going to pass I think it will
play out like this it'll play out it's
definite like the House bill the House
bill was presented and they said we're
going to rush this Russia Prussia Russia
and then it failed and then they came
back and they made some very minor
tweaks and there's a lot of public
pressure because like oh I guess we've
held out long enough and then they
passed basically the same bill as House
bill number one with a few minor tweaks
attached that didn't mean anything in
that some of which have been stripped
out by the Senate I think the same thing
will probably happen here but Rand
Paul's assessment that this is exactly
correct he says this is still Obamacare
it could still happen if the people who
wrote the bill are willing to negotiate
conservatives won a repeal bill I want
to build it looks like feels like and is
a repeal bill my fear is when I look at
this I keep reading it and it's like it
sounds like Obamacare to me doesn't even
sound like Obamacare life in some areas
it may be Obamacare Plus on the subsidy
side we can't have a bill that spends
more than Obamacare in the first couple
years and call that a repeal bill so yes
we should be reformed repeal but we also
have to have sufficient confidence in
capitalism competition and free markets
okay so what's hilarious about all of
this is that as the Republicans rightly
the conservatives in the caucus rightly
say this does not repeal Obamacare the
Democrats of course it wouldn't matter
what this did if it just said we want
the American health care the american
Care Act or the Affordable Care Act
Obamacare we just want Obamacare to be
called Obamacare we're gonna get rid of
one letter the Democrats the end of the
world we're all going to die it's the
worst thing that ever happened we if
you're going to get accused of that
anyway
you may as well make the changes you
want to make you may as well make the
changes that are actually going to
ensure the premiums come down because no
matter what you do Democrats are going
to claim that at the end of the world
you're going to kill people Elizabeth
Warren is going to go out there and say
it's blood money
here's Elizabeth Warren today saying
it's blood money she grabbed her
tomahawk and she was chancing around the
fire here's what she had to say this is
a really terrible bill and make no
mistake this bill is about tax breaks
for the rich and this bill is about
Republicans saying hey those are our
priorities we're taking care of the
people we care about and everyone else
can just bear the cost of it this is the
moment to tell the Republicans in the
United States Senate to tell every one
of the Republicans in the United States
Senate
no this bill does not represent our
values this bill is not who we are as a
country we believe that health care is a
basic human right and we will get out
there and fight for it and then she
tweeted out I've read the Republican
health care bill this is blood money
they're paying for tax cuts with
American lives blood money okay first of
all this lady takes much muchos money
from Planned Parenthood that's actual
blood money but she talked about it's
blood money and we're going to die
everyone's going to die it's the worst
thing ever this thing trims around the
edges it really does and it increases
subsidies in some areas it gets rid of
the individual mandate the idea by the
way that's Larry is that they're making
cuts and they're going to make you pay
for it who's you okay I've been paying
for Obamacare since it was in since its
inception for my tax dollars I'm paying
for Obamacare through increased premiums
in it so view so this idea that me that
we're going to change the system and
it's going to redistribute the cost one
of the great Democrat talking points
here is they keep saying well this is a
tax cut for the rich excuse me excuse me
or it's a redistribution of money from
poor to rich Obamacare was the greatest
redistributed move in modern history
moving wealth from the middle class to
the poor from moving wealth from the the
young to the old moving it from the
healthy to the sick that's what
Obamacare was and going back to status
quo ante is not actually the destruction
of some sort of grand system here but
this is what Democrats are talking like
where Chuck Schumer says the same thing
he says this would end health care
everyone's gonna die rah rah even as we
continue to get more details the broad
outlines are clear this is a bill
designed to strip away health care
benefits and protections from Americans
who need it most in order to give a tax
break to the folks who need at least
this is a bill that would end medicate
as we know it
rolling back Medicaid expansion cutting
federal support for the program even
more than the House bill which cut
Medicaid by eight hundred billion
dollars from what is reported in just
three short years under the Senate bill
Republicans will kick millions off their
Medicaid coverage
okay so again Democrats are always going
to claim this stuff Barack Obama went on
on Facebook and posted a long rant about
how terrible the bill is and how
everyone's going to die and the
Democrats are always gonna claim this
they're always going to claim this and
this is why Republicans ought to just do
whatever the hell they want and pass a
bill that does what they said it would
do and repeal this piece of crap
legislation instead of trimming around
the edges because they actually want to
keep it while lying to you about it
that's what's really nasty about all of
us okay well as we continue here on the
bench Shapiro show I want to get to the
mailbag we're going to do the mailbag
we're also going to get to president
Trump's comments about the tapes finally
we have an answer on the tapes and all
of that we will talk about that I also
want to talk about the fact that the
Obama administration really did almost
nothing to get on top of the the Putin
supposed in selection interference while
Democrats keep talking incessantly about
how they about how the election was
hacked and tell Trump's fault really if
any president's fault is President
Obama's but we'll talk about that in
just a second but for that you're going
to have to subscribe to go over to Daily
wires calm right now eight dollars a
month the prices are going about to rise
in July so if you're going to get a
subscription now is the best time to do
it for people who already subscribed the
rights are staying the same but for
people who are not you need to do it now
lock in that lower rate eight dollars a
month you get access to the mail bag you
can do the live mail bag right in to me
right now if you subscribe to the rest
of the show live C Clavin show live skip
be part of his mailbag as well and if
you subscribe to the annual subscription
they need a free signed copy of this
book by me and my father
say it so Papa dad me and the 2005 White
Sox championship season a really fun
book about baseball and fathers and sons
people from all sides of the political
aisle really enjoying it so you get a
free signed copy when you get in the
annual subscription you just want to
listen later over to iTunes SoundCloud
Google Play and and subscribe make sure
you leave us a review that always helps
boost us in the rankings we appreciate
it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]